do you remember this shoe company this
is like during like the Asian YouTube
era and the shoe came in uh company came
in really hard and they just kind of
don't say Creative Recreation I'll just
say Creative Recreation where did they
go I don't know
[Music]
isn't that crazy but that happened to me
with that guy I know God ah I know dude
enough about Colleen's love life we need
to get on with this off the Record topic
what were your favorite or what were the
hottest clothing trends when you were a
teenager oh baggy pants this is asked by
fried onion in our Discord thank you
very much and you can only ask us if
you're part of the Discord which means
you gotta be a patreon member
when you were a teenager what year was
that when you were like 16 seconds
2013 I mean sorry 2003. I don't know
when Chucks were ever out
yeah they're Timeless I think because
they look good in like rock skate Punk
gangster cholo do you ever have it with
the fat laces though like you'd switch
out the laces fat laces yeah they're
like everything baggy Dickies and a big
white T-shirt
it was always low-rise jeans what are
low-rise jeans right now they're all
high-waisted that's the style
I think it's coming back yeah I sit
lower I saw that it started to make a
comeback is it like the Christina
Aguilera pants Oh and then you go whale
tail you go whale Channel you can see
that you can see the bones yeah yeah
when that makes you go
uh like that on guys or girls
but now it's like high-waisted and like
cargo and like baggy yeah baggy big
baggy clothes were just everything and
comfortable it was easy
at the same time too there was also like
the goth and the scene kids too yeah it
depends on the scene you're in so I
remember in uh when I was in junior high
I mean yeah when I was a teenager
probably when I was 13. what I was
interested in was like baggy clothes big
white tees because you want to look like
a gangster yeah and then I remember uh
when I started getting into like break
dancing with my friends everyone's
wearing like FUBU triple five Soul uh
NYC like all those like kind of like
hip-hop try like tribal like those kind
of Brands and then I remember I got more
into like raving and stuff and that's
when a brand called Drunken Monkey came
out drunken monkey and then I remember
remember those skate shoes they're like
Globes yeah it was like it only existed
like during that time like air walks I I
had a pair of airwalks they were pretty
it was like it almost depend on what
scene you're in and it was so clear back
then like depending on the scene you
dressed a certain way that's true yeah
so my closet actually changed a bunch of
times yeah that's right because when you
become when you buy a skateboard and you
actually learn how to ollie now you
gotta get like the full-on yeah you
can't dress like anything else yeah dude
and it's weird because you couldn't just
order it online and just have it now you
got to go to a skate shop yeah go to
specific places yeah remember those Duff
shoes even tribal gear was kind of hard
to find you had to go to like a like a
booth in a in a swap meet that sold that
and the hip-hop stuff and as and then
graffiti like like can talk yeah yeah
spray tops yeah or scribes yeah illegal
[__] yeah what about Brands like uh what
were some of the mall brands that you
guys buy everyone went to Miller's
Outpost before it turned into and then
it turned into Anchor Blue I remember
that and then like holy [__] I ever
heard that name yeah dude that's bring
it back huh that was a place for jeans
before Asians were dressing like cholos
I remember they went to
um Lacoste they went to boss they went
to
um what's the other polo shirt brand
eyes uh polo
polo and then we were we're like Nautica
and oh yeah Tommy Hilfiger yeah what's
the Khaki Brandon stalkers everyone wore
Dockers yeah Nautica and Tommy were
masked there was another store too that
all the like if you're into the GQ style
there was a store that got bought out by
Express but they were called structure
was awesome yeah like if you were into
like the baggy polos where you like
barely just took this part in and
everything rolled it over destruction
was Asian gang where yeah yeah yeah
because you get good slacks there and
you get your hair and Asian kingware
yeah you you get your baggy pull
you you pull it out like you got a
fan and same with Banana Republic that
was a little bit of that too yeah guys
were shopping there
and then when Aeropostale came out
Aeropostale was big for just getting
cheap clothes at like a big quality was
that associated with uh
like American Eagle and I think it was
like pre yeah I think it was like a
little bit of a precursor to that um
that's what came first what's the
Abercrombie look came out then you had
Hollister American Eagle yeah then those
were huge all my like Japanese American
friends and people that like are from
like or Filipino they would uh wear like
the Hawaiian Island Creations
remember remember that shirt h-i-c like
they were I was like always thought it
was so cool like surfboard they would
wear like the poopy shell necklaces
hookahs were major for sure a lot of
Hawaii fashion made it to uh I remember
when Hawaiian shirts was trending right
yeah yeah right it's really awesome dude
at our high school oh yeah guys would
wear um
like the the long beads that you would
get at like a Hawaiian like the brown
ones no the black ones oh like have you
ever seen those they're they're not like
yeah they're called Kukui nut or
something yeah like that was the thing
and I just remember like I didn't even
know it was like a Hawaiian thing but
like everybody was wearing them or like
the shark tooth not even you know what
not even the shark tooth it was it was
just this like the black ones because I
remember like how come people don't wear
puka shells but like everybody was like
making fun of them at the time when I
was in like high school like baby shows
are lame dude but they would wear these
little what are they called they thought
they were lame at that time at my time I
guess they cut kind of were already yeah
remember chokers they also wear chokers
all the guys wearing chokers though yeah
I remember a lot of dudes dressed like
that fool guy Fury oh yeah Guy Fieri he
still dresses like that a Route 66 shirt
yeah well he has to he probably doesn't
want to but he has like a buttons
that was stuck he's stuck in 2001 dude
he looks like a diner yeah
he's like a Hoobastank fan dude like
yeah what about for pants what was the
go-to jinko for my Rave days yeah also
solos I think you guys remember solos in
the swap meet that was the gang brand
Ben Davis oh yeah Ben Davis Ben Davis
Dickies Levi's I really like Levi's
you're cool we're 501 yeah yeah five
actually I think they were five eleven
five eleven as a teenager uh yeah
no it was like later on like when I
didn't wear Dickies anymore because
Dickies was like Middle School going
into high school and I was like I'm
gonna start wearing jeans because they
fit better you know hey do you have a
picture of yourself from high school I'm
thinking of it right now because I'm
remembering people who went through like
the Ed Hardy phase Ed Hardy face
my freshman year in high school like
mostly everybody was wearing like big
white tees right and then like you know
big baggy pants yeah and they were like
shakas and pro clubs and all those
Brands but there was a thing where
chocolate yeah like people would take
your tag like they'd be like is that Pro
Club is that a pro club that's not a pro
club and they would like like talk [__]
in class all the time and I didn't know
what the [__] was going on so what they
would do was like they would rip the
tags off like that would be like a game
that they would do so that you can't be
verified something not even verified but
it was just like oh I got your attack
kinda like oh yeah I got your tag why is
that so familiar yeah like people would
do that [__] but then as I was getting
older like probably like sophomore to
junior year guys stopped wearing big
baggy tees and they started wearing like
Abercrombie which was weird and they're
like kind of like gang bangers dude so
like some of these dudes are kind of
gangster would start like it would start
to [__] kinda and it was like I don't
think I saw those guys yeah it was like
the Pharrell era where people were
starting or like yeah they would wear
like collared shirts or they just wear
like Abercrombie hoodies and then it got
even more streetwear when the first time
I saw like hundreds I was like what's
this logo everybody was like yo like we
got the hundreds and I'd be like what's
this lug with the bomb like oh that's
cool but we I never bought them because
I was like that's too expensive I
couldn't pay for them yeah but like like
diamonds they'd wear like diamonds they
may fly yeah Diamond Supply they wear
um what's called what was it the
hundreds right hundreds and then
diamonds
bro
or a life yeah that was kind of
expensive too though a lot of the cool
like like streetwear kids would wear
like a life and I'd be like oh what are
these Brands because I remember seeing
it was really cool but it was also very
exclusive and then I think 10 Deep 10
Deep 10 Deep 10 Deep kids were
undefeated
did it ever uh did they ever get Johnny
Cupcakes out there I don't know what the
hell you just oh yeah Johnny cook Johnny
Cupcakes was like deep cut streetwear
brand at the time it was like super hot
or tap out
some guys will wear like this you're
talking to an Affliction man right there
I was like you kidding me dude I got my
whole closet filled up did you really
wear tap out
um come on no not until later actually
because I had a Tap Out shirt I think
Bart gave me one for my birthday when I
was fighting when I was fighting we
would like sometimes we would have sales
for Tapout stuff
they had really tight sweatsuits and we
would wear them and we'd wear them to
cut weight so we I would buy something
no I think but you you and the homies
all pitched in and bought me a t-shirt
for my birthday and then I didn't know I
didn't know what tap out was because I
liked MMA I just didn't watch UFC I do
any of that [__] I didn't want one so
bad so they got me one I was like oh
cool and they're like you don't even
know tap out and I'm like huh that was
such a game changer you know it was you
know it was a brand I wanted to wear but
I didn't want to be a poser it was Fox
Racing Fox how come why aren't just like
a poser you're gonna be a poser if you
don't know is that the fox with the
lines for the eyes oh that was that was
cool I think it's a tail yeah what about
Metal Volusia dude
militia they sponsored the Diaz brothers
yeah yeah
I remember yeah because I remember
seeing that transition and being like Oh
that's kind of crazy what were the
brands that your parents put you in
against your will when you Oshkosh
[__] ask Oshkosh but gosh bro you
know what brand they put me that [__]
hate it and I was like [__] I should
have kept all that [__] in elementary
school so my aunt went to fit him she
was a designer and then so she would buy
me all these like polo shirts that are
actual Polo [__] Polo uh uh the like
the Khaki jackets and all that stuff
like Ralph Lauren Poland yeah Ralph
Lauren polo and uh but I'm like in
fourth grade or something I want Bugle
Boy I don't want that [__] dad [__]
I'm gonna I want to be abused yeah I'm
gonna go [__] scratch someone's car
later you know so I wanted like that
like that kind of mischievous clothing
or like no fear you know no fear was
cool Quicksilver dude yeah or like who's
the boss and it's a [__] duck on it
or some [__] and then she would give me
like those clothes and then in junior
high when that became in I was like [__]
I wish it was so cool
yeah
dude I had a lot of Union
[Music]
yeah it's like a JCPenney brand same
with like mashimo those were like those
are like department store stuff yeah
they went to Target I remember when they
went to Target and they always wearing I
was wearing most of them all back then
bro when it was at Target kind of
JCPenney I love that we're fighting
Pockets to brag yeah yeah yeah where are
they now oh dude we know what happened
tomorrow there used to be a clear
distinction between mall clothes and
like you knew you got it at Target or
somewhere else yeah yeah you can't tell
you can't tell yeah it's just all
graphic tees and like whatever yeah I
remember my sisters used to like
they used to buy me clothes and be like
just wear this and I would just like
wear their like wear clothes wear their
clothes yeah I'd wear their clothes
um but they would like shop at um I
remember just when like h m started
being a thing oh wow yeah and they would
like like you should wear this and I'll
be like they're trying to dress you up
you're lucky to have h m as a younger
person yes it was affordable and then
they would go to like Forever 21 they
would just buy me clothes and they'd be
like they're like oh Nick's gonna look
good in this and then they put it on and
I was like okay like that stupid you're
like their little doll yeah kind of do
you remember this shoe Cup this is like
during like the Asian YouTube era and
the shoe came in uh company came in
really hard and they just kind of don't
say Creative Recreation I wasn't saying
Creative Recreation where did they go I
don't know it was like every single
Asian YouTuber was wearing it and then
it just they were trying to hit the
dance Market too like it's really hard
who's behind that creative breakfast a
nice shoe yeah like how does the how do
things come so hard so fast and leaf I
went I remember I went to like uh I know
lot of like brothers started wearing
creative wrecks too like a lot of black
dudes had him and I was like what is
this Market it's like all like Urban
like black dudes and then just Asian
dancers like who's the person in charge
kind of tired dude I had we wore those
for ABDC yeah we did too yeah how did it
come so fast they had him at like they
were making deals with wardrobe
departments on shows and they were given
creative wrecks out to just everyone on
set so it was like somebody I never met
the guy behind that at all comment below
if you're a part of Creative Rec
creative Creative Rec we're actually
cool unlike I mean that vlado was
another big dance scene seller but it
wasn't as cool as creative wreck yeah
yeah damn I'm surprised you know about
that that's crazy I just remember seeing
everyone it's a dancer to it
it was also another brand called rat eye
I don't know if you remember rat eye
r-a-d-i-i they look like Supras but they
were oh yeah Supras were cool I have a
bunch that I got rid of recently oh dang
it wasn't the bags of stuff supers had
they had really high value though I
remember I didn't know what I was buying
when I would buy them and I would just
get random ones and then if I went to
like another country and I was wearing
them everybody would freak out and go
how are you dancing in those like you're
gonna wreck those it's like like I got
it for 60 bucks yeah they're like
regular 60 shoes out here oh you know
what shirts that actually start to
collect things I like them and it was
also because I couldn't really afford
them so it took me a while to save to
get one it was a LRG remember LRG that
was another but each shirt is like 30 40
yeah and it's full of t-shirt and then
so it's like you can't just go and just
buy three because that's already 100
bucks I'd buy one and then maybe a
couple months later I'll buy another one
dude I had a sick track jacket an LRG
tractor yeah if I got like a [__]
ketchup stain on I feel like my life was
over yeah
hey
we had a meeting with the Quest Crew we
had a meeting with the LRG guy passed
away a couple weeks before he died yeah
yeah we were supposed to uh he was
supposed to sponsor us against gear and
we were supposed to rep it and stuff but
then he passed away yeah it was like a
tree with a plus sign yeah yeah I always
thought that it was a Cool brand allergy
was a very cool brand yeah it was very
hip-hop brand it was so big too yeah it
was so big of the big fit yeah like
everybody was wearing them every it was
like it was a very popular brand
everywhere what's the girl brands of
your teen years they were so white like
Roxy oh my god
did you shop with that limited too but
they're still around Wet Seal yeah I
spent so many times
I've been in all those stores that's
where all I went to a ball and when yeah
those are all the stores my sisters went
to and I'll just be like yeah there's so
much
I remember those yeah what was your
go-to
I mean all the ones out of name did you
have this the sweats the matching sweats
where the butt is Juicy yeah
I had like the the
um velvet jacket that was like a Paris
Hilton like oh yeah that was a staple
she made those Poppins yeah low rise
velvet jumpsuit what store when you go
to the mall and you're gonna go shop
what stores which one gets your butt
twitching as you're walking towards it
as a teenager yeah I think it was like
you're like that's my [__] I mean I
think it was just Forever 21 at the time
because it was just like they had so
much like variety
and it was just easy it was cheap yeah
um you know so preferred someone almost
got popular dude it was on top for quite
a long time they kind of just fell off
yeah they're only now closing a bunch of
them do you think now is it h m hmm
what's now the equivalent probably h m
now nowadays honestly it's probably she
and oh she is
like it's the place that they produce
clothes at such a higher rate than any
other product everybody hates them with
their clothes are like yeah it's fast
fashion times a million is it like from
China literally all the things you could
think about that's bad about a clothing
company like you know they steal ideas
people have gotten their packages and
it's like all [__] up they're
sometimes they get roaches in there like
oh my God yeah bro their shirts it's
probably child labor terrible right so
it's like Forever 21 but by Chinese
people but like way worse yeah I mean I
think she was Chinese anyway right the
fair 21 Creator no they're Koreans yeah
because because Koreans have a little
bit of standards and then Chinese yeah
yeah so she and nobody can take a style
that's like like let's say a style is
trending nobody can bring that to Market
at mass than fashion when she is wow
it's so quick you think they're gonna go
out of business sorry not Sheen she in
is one of them the one worse than that
is boohoo I think what the hell is
boohoo never heard of it what
yeah yeah because they have physical
stores oh they do don't they I love
their Billboards yeah like oh man why I
want to I want to try them out do they
have clothes for men yes yes I thought
they just sponsored big booty Brazilian
girls they sponsored Tim for a while oh
you guys ever buy Amazon Basics clothing
no is it good uh I just bought a pair of
jeans just because yeah I was like oh it
fits really nice oh [__] I want to get
their shirts just regular plain shirts I
mean no I don't really wear them anymore
but when I did wear them I was like I
like how basic it looks they're gonna
take over the world oh because I got
tired of wearing the basics yeah do they
have Amazon bases of everything how
about puppy pads that are Amazon Basics
it was like what that's crazy yeah it's
their own [__] it's scary dude I mean
now that there's like no way to stop
people from like manufacturing clothes
that look like other stuff
like it's Unstoppable now
especially if you do it that fast damn
man you think all the kids are wearing
Amazon Basics these days no I'm not
right I'm sure lots of people dude it's
cheaper than h m no for sure dude yeah
can't compete with Amazon you probably
get it you know what I think it's gonna
happen right now there's gonna be a
whole new market that's like
handmade
designer high quality super high quality
super expensive
but like you could only get it from this
person and nobody's gonna buy it I
thought you would say super no sales
if you gotta hand make it turn around
times long do you remember do you
remember any of the brands that were not
clothes of just things you had in your
teen years like like the gel we used oh
dude ballet looks Bella Bella yeah got
to be the Bella I remember got to be I
would use got to be from got to be still
I think it's still around yeah or it's
still there yeah
what else got to be remember like
Mitsubishi TVs oh [__] I forgot they had
TV like people would have like big
screen TVs but it's like big in the back
and it's like by Mitsubishi wow I did it
all yeah I don't know I've seen those
but I had Panasonic stop bragging Iowa I
was I was yeah I was gone and their
sound system yeah remember like you had
like the stack it could play like record
and all that and it's all attached with
the speakers that's totally gone right
Iowa I don't know maybe she's not here
oh damn but it was like that but it was
cool to see like Brands like Fila come
back you know like from 90s or starter
it was cool seeing Stars oh that starter
jacket okay Swiss okay Swiss K-Swiss
Gary V bought it right or yeah he did
you think so I like K-Swiss I have a
pair well no I'm not wearing you got the
garyvee's you got the Gary V5 oh but it
has memory foam in it it's really for
real yeah like to make you talk
high-pitched a little bit or no no but
every time I wear the case Swiss people
are like whoa you got nice white shoes
I'm like thanks like is that Fila or
something like no it's K-Swiss the Gary
Beast do you guys ever remember getting
made fun of at school for for something
specific that you were wearing oh on
every day oh yeah it was all the clothes
my sisters made me wear I got super move
I remember uh my first day of school in
eighth grade uh one of my friends made
fun of me goes like oh you're one of
those last year and I was like I don't
know
you know when the Sketchers came out
everyone got those Sketchers it was kind
of spiky in the bottom and then what it
was like a weird Adidas knockoff oh I
got a Payless knockoff yeah oh [__] and
then I wore it to school and then
everyone's like PayLess PayLess like
everyone knew and I'm like thinking now
I'm like how did they all know it was
Payless if they never been to Payless
but they're laughing him do I remember
Payless a lot of guys would get um the
moccasins that was the thing where
people wear like the brown moccasins
from Payless and I would wear them too
because they're mad comfy uh like
everybody was wearing them and it was
like the shoe wear at the time but it's
Payless I never remember anything from
Payless that was popular I had like a
traumatic experience at Payless when I
was a kid because I went there for the
first time with my parents and they were
like yeah just pick whatever you want
and I went down the line and I found
some cool Converse that were like yellow
and then uh I showed it to the worker
here and I was like oh do you have these
I was like a little ass kid and the
worker went those are for girls and you
know how embarrassing that is as like a
young
young she was laughing she wasn't like
giggling she was like straight laughing
she was probably like 16. and I was like
I don't want shoes here anymore mom but
you know what they were they were the
yellow uh converse with the Tweety Bird
on it oh tight you remember those they
used to have yeah you said but Converses
are unisex they had Looney Tunes
characters on him and that's the only
reason she was like those are girls
shoes that's so dumb is for boys too
because you wanted a Tweety Boy the boy
one was the Taz one oh yeah
[Music]
oh